Okay, it says I'm supposed to read the prompter
and we have another surprise.
It's a surprise guest, I have no idea who it is.
I don't even know what I'm saying right now.
♪ We got the beat, we got the beat ♪
♪ Yeah, we got it ♪
(audience cheering)
Oh my God!
(audience clapping)
Hi.
(audience cheering)
Baby.
Oh my God, oh my God.
Aww.
Belinda Carlisle, Jane Wiedlin,
Gina Schock, Charlotte Caffey, and Kathy Valentine.
The Go-Gos everybody.
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh.
The last time we saw each other was at
the rock and roll hall of fame.
And I was lucky enough to honor you guys,
how has that been?
You guys feeling good about that nod that you so deserve?
We were so excited to have you Drew.
(audience clapping)
And I am so happy, we are all very happy
that we're celebrating your birthday with you Drew.
Because we really do adore you sweetheart,
and we're all really proud of you.
We've watched you grow up,
and you've turned out beautifully baby.
You're just fabulous.
(audience clapping)
"We Got The Beat" was released 40 years ago.
Give me a memory from 40 years ago if you don't mind.
Mine is when we recorded it.
And we went in the recording studio,
and ready and rearing to get "We Got The Beat",
and we played it and then we played it again.
Then we played it again.
And after the tenth try our producer Richard said,
"Okay, let's take a break."
And he ordered pizza.
It was either the magic sauce in the pizza,
or the stars aligned while we were eating.
Or maybe both, but that the 11th take was magic.
And we are just so happy that
we get to share that with you today.
I love being behind the scenes, that's so exciting.
What was the inspiration for that album cover?
The cover as well as what was inside and all you guys
was just such a life changer.
It's a really iconic image and I don't know...
You realize that our main goal was not to
date the record and not like see it 20 years later.
And oh, look at those hairstyles and whatnot.
I believe it was Belinda's idea, was it babe?
Was it your idea?
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know how it came about.
I thought that...
Being in towels and masks,
and about beauty, and not being any sort of dated fashion,
it's a timeless cover.
I know speaking for myself and the band
that we're so happy to be able to
celebrate this birthday with you.
We feel like you're really one of us,
to be perfectly honest.
(audience clapping)
I know I wouldn't be the same person
if you weren't who you were.
Because you did, you just gave us all permission
to dream and think big, and be proud.
And all of us who are your fans...
(audience clapping)
Okay, I'm seeing in the prompter.
There's a surprise for me.
Oh God.
Drew, we love you so much,
and we've just fallen in love with you all over again
that so many years later.
And so we want to invite you to be the sixth Go-Go.
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
Oh my God.
Thank you to the Go-Go's.
Melinda Carlisle, Jane Wiedlin, Gina Schock,
Charlotte Caffey and Kathy Valentine.
And please check out the entire inductee ceremony
of the rock and roll of hall of fame.
It is a true love letter from a true blue fan
to the greatest women on earth.